Justices start out on swivel chairs just
like the real justices but then
eventually those chairs are rolling all
around the stage the podium rolls around
the stage and eventually some actual
total nudity gets involved in the
argument as well the woolly mammoth
theater in Washington DC is hosting the
play arguendo I had a recording of the
oral argument from this case called
Barnes versus Glenn theater which was
hands-down the most entertaining
director John Collins combines the
Supreme Court's stodgy decision to
uphold state bans on nudity and
businesses open to the public with the
burlesque nature of experimental theatre
it's a case about some erotic dancers in
South Bend Indiana
who were afraid they were gonna get
arrested for dancing totally naked in
these clubs like the kitty cat lounge
and so they challenged the law there was
a law on the books for a long time that
said you can't be naked in public in
Indiana they argue that they had a First
Amendment right to be naked so you will
what you hear in ru endo is exactly what
you would have heard in the courtroom
the set is dominated by a sort of
projection screen that creates the back
wall and it's got animated texts flying
all over it so every time somebody cites
a case or a precedent or or quotes a law
or a prior opinion those words come
flying into focus behind them argue
window is accompanied by an interactive
exhibit allowing the audience to explore
the arguments and form its own opinion I
hope what you're left with is that it's
not the easiest case in the world that
there are interesting questions on both
sides of it it's not difficult to see
that our sympathies would lie with the
dancers since they are the performers
claiming their First Amendment right and
I guess I guess we imagine or hope that
we have the kind of protection that
they're asking for but we love the case
because it's about performance it's
about the uniqueness and the expressive
meaning of live performance versus other
kinds of performance is this First
Amendment free speech or is this just
you know something you do in a sleazy
part of town
some men turned on in some way or
another we we really relate to all of
those questions because we think live
performance is full of those ambiguities
and it's an exciting part of doing it
you